That is very
nice. Welcome. Very nice. I appreciate
it. Very spontaneous. So thank you.
Thanks Jess for having me here
today. I appreciate it. Um,
so what I wanted to chat a little bit
with you guys about today and an end.
First of all, thank you for having
me here. I'm excited to be here. Um,
is the importance of bravery in marketing
and why that's so important really in
today's marketing landscape
and in the world that is, um,
really so focused on
technology and data and um,
how we intercept kind of the,
the art and the science of marketing.
And if you look at just the
technical definition of bravery,
it's this idea of the quality or state
of having or showing mental or moral
strength to face danger,
fear or difficulty.
So those are really powerful words when
you think about them in the business
context,
but from the lens of a Cmo,
why are they so important? Well, they're
important for a number of reasons.
First and foremost, the CMO seat,
especially these days, is a hot seat.
The average tenure for a CMO is 18
months according to a recent study.
And I'm going to talk a little
bit more about this, but, um,
80% of CEOs actually say that they
don't trust their CMO and we'll get into
that.
But having bravery is a path forward.
This idea of kind of facing danger,
fear or difficulty,
I think aligns really well with
this idea that I'm talking about.
And I think in a world where people are
so overwhelmed with choice and people
have so little time in their day anymore
that you have to be brave to break
through. And as marketers, that's
what we're really trying to do.
We're trying to break through and make
an emotional engagements with people.
And it's more difficult than ever before.
And I think we know a little bit about
bravery. If you think about my company,
ally financial and what we did.
So think about the fact that like you
guys were a pretty young company 10 years
ago. We didn't even exist,
which is hard to believe.
And what we did is we launched in the
worst financial crisis since the Great
Depression.
We were spun off from General Motors,
we were GMS captive auto finance company.
And GM was going through its
bankruptcy and needed liquidity.
And so the idea was to sell the captive
and all of a sudden we found ourselves
in a marketplace where we
had been engineered and built
to do one thing and that
was to serve auto loans to GM dealers.
Suddenly we're in this complete financial
crisis where is markets are crashing
down. There's no access to liquidity.
We have no mothership anymore. Gm has,
and we had to change or die and we had
thousands of people that were depending
on us as employees of ally,
but bigger than that,
we had 17,000 dealers that were
dependent on us to survive.
And we had really the responsibility of
a huge impact on the American economy if
GMHC went down.
And so what we had to do is start from
scratch and we had to rethink the way
that we were going to
go to market completely.
And we really felt like there's this
huge opportunity and everybody was saying
to us, what are you going
to do? And our thought was,
we're going to launch a bank and the
bank is going to become the deposit
gathering capability that will fund the
auto loans and we'll kind of reinvent
ourselves to be able to
have the ability to do that.
And we're not going to
just create a normal bank.
We're going to create a
digital bank because we needed
to get to market quickly.
We didn't have time for infrastructure
to build brick and mortar locations and
we were on a very short timeframe in
order to be able to start generating
revenue before our liquidity ran out.
It kind of complicating that is
the government came to us and said,
we're going to close down Chrysler
capital and we want you to take on all the
Chrysler dealers as well.
So that added significant pressure to
our timeline and to what it was that we
needed to do. And everybody
was saying a bank, you know,
the world doesn't need another bank.
That's the last thing anybody
wants is another bank.
And our mantra at the time
was this notion that yeah,
the world doesn't need another
bank but it needs a better bank.
And we took this bet that
everybody would be banking, uh,
in the palm of their hand.
Now it seems really intuitive now,
10 years later,
as you watch all these big companies
scramble to get to digital financial
services solutions.
But 10 years ago,
there was nobody out in
the category like us.
We also saw a ton of pain points
in the category. You know,
people were either completely apathetic,
they weren't paying any attention to
how their banks, we're treating them.
And if you think about
it in a lot of ways,
we were putting up with
things that as consumers,
we shouldn't be putting up with.
Like,
why should I pay $5 to get
my money out of the wall?
Think about it. You still do
it today. Why do I have money?
My money sitting at a bank that
doesn't pay any interest on my savings?
People still do it today.
You know,
why can't I have 24 by seven service?
Money is a really important thing.
I work really hard for my money.
My family depends on my money yet if
it's past five o'clock or six o'clock and
something happens, I can't talk
to anybody at a bank. You know,
why is everything so confusing?
Why is the jargon so confusing?
Why do banks purposely try and
confuse you and hide things from you,
whether they're hidden fees,
kind of this bait and switch mentality.
So a lot of pain points and we really
felt like there was this huge opportunity
and a better way forward.
And that really is what created ally.
So literally in a six
month period of time,
back during that financial crisis,
a very small group of us pretty much
spent the whole entire summer in New York
with a branding company
and an advertising agency.
And we came up with what we thought
was a better way forward and we created
ally.
The launch was really different.
We really took on the big banks.
What we wanted to do was kind
of create this awakening.
We wanted to reach out and shake people
and get them to pay attention and get
them to pay attention to what
was happening in the category.
And also what was paying what
was happening to their money.
And so we launched in a really loud
and disruptive way. And you know,
as a marketer at the time,
this was really a brave campaign.
And I'll talk a little bit about um,
how it did.
I'll talk a little bit about some of
the reaction and some of the things that
occurred as a result. But the whole
business model itself was brave,
but also the way that we came to market
I think is a great example of that.
So let me play a couple of spots that
you guys may or may not remember.
This is the way that ally came to market.
Have some fun with that
truck. Okay. Times up.
Here you go. That's a
nice one. I made that
we can have the red truck seat.
That was a limited time offer only.
It's right here in the fine print.
Even kids know what's wrong,
not in fine print.
Why don't banks were allied a new bank?
Who's Rachel always be among the top
with nothing buried in the fine print.
It's just the right thing to do.
What'd you like a pony?
Would you like a pony?
Yeah.
Here you go.
Hold out on somebody.
Why don't banks were ally the new big
that alerts you when your money can be
working harder and burning more.
It's just the right thing to do.
So a really bold way to come to market
in a category that had always done,
just really boring,
really plain type of advertising.
Everything about what we did was
brave. Um, including the color, right?
A purple bank. I mean what we
did is we put up on the wall,
all bank advertising and everything
was either red, white, or blue.
If you think about it, like look around
today, you'll see the same thing.
And so we thought, we want to stand
out. We're going to be a digital bank.
We want to do something different. And
we chose the color purple. You know,
the spots.
The idea was RJ represented the big banks
and we wanted to clearly call out how
dishonorably banks were behaving and
the fact that even little kids recognize
when something is wrong, everything
was shot, hidden camera. Um,
all the cameramen were in those,
those play structures that you kind
of saw in the background there.
The kids thought that they were coming
in for focus groups and we get real
reactions and um, you know,
they just, they just blew up.
I mean it resonated.
It created that emotional
connection with people right away.
I remember shooting the one with pony and
we shot a bunch of different kids just
to get the best reactions.
And we shot these two sisters and um,
they came in and they did the, you know,
Rj did the, do you want a pony? Yes.
Do you want a pony?
And I was sitting with their mom in the
green room and when the other sister got
the real pony,
the other little sister turned to her
and punched her right in the face.
I'm like,
I really want to use that one,
but we decided to go
with this one instead.
But it was a really great way for us to
come to market and it really helped us
build a brand and it helped us get in the,
get on the landscape very,
very quickly.
And if you kind of fast forward now
10 years later and look at how we,
how we've done, it's been
unbelievable. We have um,
1.4 million customers of
ally bank on the auto side,
four and a half million customers.
So all total about five and a half
million customers that we do business with
today in 10 years,
nine almost $95 billion in deposits.
And this is is for something where there's
no brick and mortar people are just
interacting with us online and
we've grown to be a top 25 bank.
Our Bank CEO was named one of the top
10 most powerful women in banking last
year.
And we've built a company from the ground
up by being brave and going to market
in a very different way and
creating something where
we saw a ton of white space
and a ton of opportunity in a time where
there was a category that needed to be
disrupted in a category
that needed to be shaken up.
The other thing that we've done along
the way is we've built this incredibly
magical brand.
And you know,
our CEO talks about his six strategic
priorities and the one thing that he talks
about in his priorities,
his brand as a weapon.
And I think that's a huge testament
to what we've done from a marketing
perspective because marketing's been a
catalyst for helping build this brand and
then having the right internal inertia,
much like you guys do,
to back up the promise of what the
brand stands for. A couple of years ago,
Boston consulting group did a list of
the up and coming brands to watch and it
was um, you know, it was Hulu,
it was Tesla, it was Gopro,
it was snapchat, it was Airbnb, an ally.
No other banks on that list and know
fortune 500 companies on that list.
Last year,
Gail and Seagal did a list of
their top disruptor brands and um,
same kind of list,
Uber and Grub hub and Airbnb and Spotify,
an ally.
So very different kinds of brands.
But I underscores what we've done and
how we've been disruptive and how we've
used bravery to really create an
entirely new category on something.
If you think about it,
that's been around for over 100 years.
So as we kind of fast forward now 10
years later and look at where we're at.
Last year we made a a big strategic pivot
and we decided that we were going to
expand our product portfolio given
how much consumers really liked doing
business with us on the banking side
and the fact that we only had savings
products, we wanted to expand
rapidly. So we launched,
we bought a company and we had, we
launched an all online investing platform,
so self directed and managed portfolios.
We stood up very quickly
a mortgage capability.
We partnered with another company and we
stood up a credit card and we purchased
a company in California to do
direct to consumer auto lending,
kind of like a lending tree model,
but to have the ability to be able to
reach into consumers and not just have to
work with the dealers on indirect lending,
but give us that indirect
lending platform.
We're also in the process of completely
reinventing our auto business to be the
digital choice for dealers as dealers.
Businesses are transforming.
And that category is finally starting
to catch up to the rest of the retail
world.
How do we power dealers so that any way
that a consumer wants to interact with
them digitally, we can be at the
center of those interactions,
giving them what they need
from a lending standpoint.
So this necessitated a change in pace
in terms of how we were going to market.
And again, we needed to be very
disruptive and we needed to be very brave.
You know, we're in a category
that spends ferociously,
the financial services category spends
over $2 billion a year on advertising,
and we're less than 2% share of
voice in that category. So for me,
the challenge was how do we kind
of outwit, outlast, outplay,
how do we break through and do things
that are very different than what
everybody else is doing in the category?
So we repositioned ourselves,
moving to this positioning of a relentless
ally for your financial wellbeing.
And We created a campaign that we wanted
to kind of humanize ourselves since we
didn't have brick and mortar and
people couldn't walk into a branch,
we wanted to do something that was fun,
something that was differentiated
that showed the people of ally being
relentless and kind of going over
the top and doing things in a really
interesting way for there,
for our customers.
So we try to be disruptive and literally
everything we did we use disruptive
creative.
I'm going to show you a couple pieces of
creative and a second really changed up
our look in terms of our graphic
design and our visual look.
I mean when you kind of look at this plum
and our people in the advertising and
the headlines to have that, that
clever wit and they just broke through.
They weren't like anything else that you
were seeing in our category or really
in any other category for that,
for that matter.
We used really differentiated media,
so we partnered with a lot of content
providers that we had never partnered with
before. You know, pop sugar and vice.
We did a really cool promotion called
Lucky Penny where we actually, um,
get this idea that people hate pennies.
You know,
the US government is thinking
about not minting pennies anymore.
They stopped minting pennies and Canada.
I get them and I throw them out or you
always leave him in that little jar at
the convenience store cause no
one wants to carry them around.
And so we wanted to create something
interesting around this idea that a penny
saved is a penny earned and that even
the smallest amount of savings can go a
long way.
And so we hid 10 pennies in
10 cities across the country,
each worth $1,000.
There were ally branded pennies and we
used social media to push out clues about
where those pennies were.
And we created this
unbelievable groundswell of
activity around people getting
together and trying to go
find those pennies and the
stories that came out of it
or unbelievable.
And it got so big that
Jimmy Kimmel actually did a
segment on it where Guillermo
actually went outside in la,
set up a tent and had people come in
where he had a sign outside that said a
penny for your thoughts.
And they filmed all this really funny
content of people coming in asking
Guillermo question,
him answering the question with something
outrageous that made literally no
sense collecting all these pennies and
then looking for the ally lucky penny.
So these were ways where we were able
to get our brand in front of people and
really different and unique use of media.
We created a lot of really
interesting partnerships,
partnered with influencers that we
had never partnered with before.
People like big and rich who are very
differentiated people in the country,
music space that do things their own way.
And Danny Coker,
we sponsored ICC, um, which is the
international soccer friendlies.
We even created an entire fragrance line
around the idea that people's favorite
smell is the smell of a new car.
So we created a line of fragrances called
new car smell and we had 15 different
fragrances that we displayed at auto shows
that were all around this idea of SUV
smell and minivans smell.
We had people walking around auto shows
with scent strips, handing them out.
Just like when you go
into a department store,
you had the ability on an
iPad to create your own scent.
And then we surprise 50 people from each
auto show and we actually made their
scent and send it to them.
So really just different ways to
go out and do interesting things.
We created something called
our disruptor calendar and um,
we did things like lucky penny. We
created an APP called a splurge alert APP.
And what you did with the splurge alert
APP is you actually downloaded the app
and then you could go into it and you
put into the app what your financial
Kryptonite is.
So for me it might be like
Nordstrom's or a Prada store,
car dealership or a wine store.
And then we fence those locations.
And every time you walked
into one of those locations,
you got an alert from the ally splurge
alert app that would say like, Andrea,
get the hell out of there. Last
time you were there, you know,
it was a bad scene and they were
all really fun and humorous.
And then you actually got to pick splurge
buddies and it pushed an alert to your
splurge buddies. Kind of like
a, not that I know. And um,
and those people could text you and say,
what are you doing?
Like you're saving for your kid's College,
get out of Nordstrom.
So it was a really fun way to get people
to think about their money differently
without preaching to them.
And then we really went
on the offensive with PR,
but we had never really used earned
media as anything but reactive.
And so we went out and got very,
um,
I think differentiated and brave
in terms of what we doing with Pr.
One of the things that we did that was
just really interesting is we were an
online bank and if you're an online bank,
your phone needs to be
charged at every moment.
Because if you want to interact
with your money, you need a,
you need a phone that's working.
So we actually had drones
that were branded with the
ally logo and we passed out
phone chargers in malls through these
drones and it was just a really cool way.
They were ally branded phone chargers
and we've got a ton of PR out of it,
a lot of earned media and it was a really
interesting and disruptive way to do
something different.
Now the one common thread that I can tell
you through all of this is that every
single point of it,
somebody told me how dumb the idea was.
Somebody told me that it was a
dangerous thing to do for our brand.
Somebody told me why it would fail,
somebody told me why we shouldn't do it.
And the one thing that we did the entire
way is we filtered out the noise and we
put our heads down and we use the golden
gut and we believed in what we were
doing and we pushed forward.
I can't tell you how many things like
the splurge your Lord App where somebody
said to me,
what's the business case for this?
Let me see what the Roi is going
to be on this. What are your KPIs?
And that's kind of the world
we live in today. You know, um,
everything is testable and everybody
wants to know what the data says.
And while you have to use the
data to make informed decisions,
you can't let the data prevents you
from doing things that you know are the
right things to do and you have to
forge forward and you have to take the
consequences, good or bad. Not
everything that we did was awesome.
Not everything that we did was successful,
but the vast majority of
what we did was successful.
We have our highest brand awareness
that we've had in our company's history.
Our brand engagement scores went from
43% to over 90% right now our likability
scores are all in the 90s our
business has never been better.
Our stock was at $15 a share
when we started this campaign.
It's near $30 a share a year.
And a half later.
So I encourage you guys to think
about the importance of bravery,
filter out the noise and just push
forward and do what you need to do.
I'm going to play the launch
spot that launched the um,
the new campaign and I
think when you see it,
I think it's a great testament of what
I'm talking about relative to kind of
doing things different
in this banking space.
Remember here at ally,
nothing stops us from doing right by our
customers is with me. Hi Man. Damn man.
Tiny.
Wait, wait, wait. Where's Tina
doing the hand thing? Yup.
We're all in for our
customers ally with right.
Sarah was like Motley Crue.
Are you kidding me? You know,
even our board was like,
I think the lead singer died
from a drug overdose. I'm like,
everybody dried from died from
a drug overdose that, I mean,
who are we going to find that didn't a
really different way to come to market.
A really different way to
kind of reposition our brand.
Show are people doing over the
top things and just have fun.
And what ended up happening as a result
of this spot is it caught fire and
everybody in social was talking
about doing the hand thing.
And so we stoked the fire by immediately
jumping on it and having a contest and
telling people to send in their best
content of them doing the hand thing.
And then we surprised and delighted
people with different prizes for the best
pictures or the best content that came in.
So again,
just kind of doing things differently,
being brave and getting
outside of the space.
Recently we did something around the
Superbowl that I wanted to show you guys.
Um, this was, I think another
moment of bravery, right?
Which is this idea that everybody can
buy every big market or can buy a spot on
the super bowl if they want.
But for us,
felt like it was duplicitous to spend a
couple million dollars on a spot in the
Superbowl when we're out there telling
our customers to think about having a
savings mindset.
So we wanted to take advantage of the
biggest day of consumerism by intercepting
it and interrupting it
in a really unique way.
So I'm going to show you a
video that I think will, um,
give you a good sense of it and we'll
talk a little bit about how it did.
I Want my children to know that they
always have a place to come back to.
Something need to be done about what was
going on in our inner city when she got
injured.
It was upsetting given back to them
with whatever I earn is one of my top
priorities.
So again, a very different way to go
to market in a time when you know,
all brands are spending millions of
dollars to get you to buy a bag of Doritos
or a mountain dew by producing
giant television spots.
We did something,
I think much different than that,
and we created this virtual reality APP.
And again,
a lot of questions around it. You
know, what if the APP doesn't work,
what if it crashes that night?
What if other brands are mad at us?
Because the APP only activated
during the commercial breaks.
So that was the only
time that you could play.
And we are taking eyes away from the
investment that people had in their
Superbowl spots. And again, yeah, there
was some risk to it. We had never done it.
We didn't know how the
technology would work. Um,
Mercedes had a bit of a fiasco with the
virtual reality idea during the super
bowl. And um, for us
it turned out awesome.
We had a million and a half people
that came to our micro site.
We were, um, number two, um,
most downloaded app that
week in, um, in your store.
We were number four.
Um,
on apple we had 70,000
downloads of the APP.
We had 660,000 rounds of the game played.
And what we did is we had the top 15
scores submitted and we selected the best
stories and the high scores merged
those two together and we granted those
people's wishes and now we're getting
the outgrowth of all of the PR that went
along with that. And I think just
to kind of punctuate, you know,
the different way that we
went to market on this,
our CEO last week wrote a handwritten
note to each one of the big save winners
and congratulated every single
one of them on behalf of ally.
So a really cool way to again be brave,
disrupt and do something really different,
especially in the face of a lot of
people saying, why are you doing this?
And I don't think it's
the right thing to do.
I'm not going to go through
all of this in detail,
but I've been doing a presentation and,
and just a part of it when,
when we are together, um, in
December. But you know, the,
these are the kinds of things that I
think cmos have their eyes on right now.
And these are the kinds of things that
keep us up at night as we think about the
best way to come to market and marketing
in this brave new world. You know,
I always say to my team,
marketing's changed more in the last
five years than it's changed in probably
the 25 years proceeding that.
And we have to be on a
constant learning agenda.
I would say I probably spend two thirds
of my time doing my actual job and a
third of my time on this learning agenda.
And it's really the reign of digital
disruption and the way that people are
interacting with brands that has changed
the way that we have to behave as
marketers. And you look at
some of these things, right?
Personalized Omni channel experiences.
This idea that people want to be able to
interact with your brand regardless of
which device they come in on.
You guys know that.
But for a lot of big brands
that are in the ecommerce space,
it's a really hard thing to get right.
You know,
this idea of speed is of the essence
and how impatient people have become,
you know, the attention span now of
the average consumer is eight seconds.
I read a statistic the other day that
was staggering that because of the,
because of technology and the ability
technology has given us to multitask,
the average person packs 34 hours
of activity into a 12 hour day.
That's staggering. So as marketers,
how do we give people's thumbs to stop?
How do we get people to look up? How do
we get people to pay attention? You know,
keeping customer attention,
not losing people.
This idea of relevance versus cool.
We argue about this all the time.
What's more important to be a cool
brand or to be a relevant brand?
And our thought is relevant because the
definition of cool is changing all the
time. You know, I think about
this idea that with all this data,
like I talked about with all this
reliance on everybody's first response,
always being, well that's a testable
proposition. You know, brand matters.
85% of people still say that their
purchases are driven by an emotional
connection and that they'll spend more
money to do business with the brand that
they have an emotional connection with.
So as a Cmo,
continuing to drive that
is really important.
And then the last one on here,
which is I think a kind of a new and
emerging one that takes an incredible
amount of bravery is this
idea of taking a stand.
It's really interesting in the political
climate that we're in right now,
people are personifying brands,
right?
They expect us to have an opinion on
things and it doesn't matter which side of
the fence that you're on,
but with all the issues that are emerging
with all of the movements that are
emerging with the,
a lot of the vitriol that's being
spewed in the political climate,
people want to know we're brand stand
and it's not okay to be neutral anymore.
You can't take a pass,
but how do you keep your brand safe?
You know when you're wearing two
hats like me as marketing and PR,
how do I keep my CEO out of hot water?
When consumers want to know where
he personally stands on gun safety?
How do we keep our company safe?
When people want to know where we
stand on large societal issues,
it's a really interesting space that
we've never had to deal with before.
Five years ago, people didn't care
what brands thought about stuff.
Now they won't do business with you if
you don't have an opinion on things.
So bravery I think is more
important than ever before.
And for me, um, and I think this
is probably a good segway into,
into the questions. Um, bright
braveries just never been a choice.
It's always kinda been a way of life.
I recently got remarried in December,
but prior to that,
and you know,
I had been a single mom for about
15 years raising two boys and,
um,
you know,
how do you work and raise two boys
and have the bravery when you're in an
important job to stand up in
the middle of a meeting and say,
I've got to go to my son's hockey
game and I'm leaving. Um, you know,
I've always been a woman
in an industry full of men,
whether it was automotive
or financial services,
it was always me and all the guys
sitting around the table. And, um,
you know,
it's just different for a
woman in business and we'll
probably talk a little bit
more about that as well.
But having the bravery to kind of stay
true to who I am and stay true to what I
believe in,
but also being able to interact in
that setting and around those tables.
And then always having big
responsibility at very young ages. Um,
and guy and I were laughing a little bit
before we came into here if maybe a lot
of it is just people haven't caught
up with me yet or figured it out.
But you know, I had my
second son, I was um,
I think 35 years old.
I came back from maternity leave,
I had two kids under two years old
and all of a sudden I was the account
director on the Chevrolet
Account, a Campbell, he walled
the youngest person ever,
the only woman in the 99
year history of the account.
And I found myself kind of thrust into
a really interesting space at a very
young age.
And how do you have that credibility
and how do you maneuver through that?
And for me,
it just always return to that one thing.
And it was that idea of being brave and
saying what was on my mind and having a
voice and not being afraid to push on
the issues that were important to me and
not being afraid to say,
I kind of am what I am.
And if people don't like it,
then I'm probably not right in this
culture and I'm not right in this job.
And knowing that you can't
operate in a world of fear,
that you have to operate
from a position of strength.
And I've always kind of governed myself
by the saying that good is the enemy of
great.
And I guess that's kind of what I want
to leave you guys with is always pushed
for great braveries that spine
that runs through all of it.
But just remember, it's okay,
you can always find another job.
You're going to be okay. But at the
end of the day when your career's over,
you want to be able to look at yourself
and have integrity and know that you did
things the way you wanted to do things.
And you always stay true to who you were.
So hopefully you got kind of out of the
examples and the things I talked about
why it's so important.
I think you're at a perfect company to
continue to have this bravery to lead the
charge in the advancements of where
this crazy rain of digital disruption is
going and to um,
kind of never forget about staying true
to what your culture means and what it
means to you and why you're here.
So thank you guys.
Despite all the technical glitches we
got through it and I appreciate your
patience.
Thank you.
Sure.
Yo,
thank you so much for joining us and
talking about what brave means to you and
my pleasure.
I think one of the biggest things that
as a company that we can take away is um,
the fact about the golden gut.
Um,
the Golden God haven't heard that used
in a long time know that gut feeling of
what's really right versus wrong rather
than always being about the data.
And it was a big data company.
I think we get stuck with ourselves,
with the clients.
Um,
a lot of different audiences about a hesby
day to day to data. And we never knew,
never use us.
Yeah.
Can you provide an example of when you
had to really go home or with your gut
than what the data was telling me?
Yeah,
absolutely. I mean that first campaign
that I showed you guys, truck and pony,
um, you know, the, the visceral
reaction from people was, uh,
it's mean you're being mean to
the little kids. Um, you know,
you shouldn't take on the big banks.
You're going to really piss everybody off.
Isn't there a softer
way to come into this?
Why do you have to go out and kind of
poke the bear if you went out? And,
um,
it required a lot of bravery.
It required us as a marketing team to
kind of unite and come together and say,
if you really want to make impact,
if you really want to change things,
you've got to go this direction. And I
knew there a lot of risk in it. I mean,
the reality was if it failed,
I'd probably get fired.
But it was okay because we just felt
like it was the right thing to do. And,
um, we pushed forward. And
honestly, you know, to this day,
it's 10 years later and people
still talk about that campaign.
It really defined us. It
put us on the map. And, um,
last year was the 10
year anniversary of it.
And we actually brought the little
kids back now 10 years later.
And with the launch of the duet,
right campaign, we said, all right,
we played a mean trick on you at the
time and now we're going to do things the
right way.
And so we gave that little girl a pony.
We gave her a real pony and we brought
the monster truck kid back. And, um,
we actually, we blindfolded him and
we had them like in a giant arena,
kind of like, you know, Ford field.
And, um, when we took the blindfold off,
there was all these monster trucks and
we let them tear it up in a bunch of
monster trucks for the
afternoon. So, you know,
it's just a cool way to
bring it full circle.
So with your teams though, in
that Golden God, do you have,
how do you keep them engaged on that?
Knowing that the number,
where's it going, you know, um,
one in a, you'll find this. Uh,
but we don't pretest anything.
So I don't pretest any creative.
I don't believe in it. Now,
thankfully I have a CEO that doesn't
want to see pretesting and isn't really
focused on it, but there's a
lot of times where he'll say,
I don't think that's a good spot
and I don't think we should do it,
but I trust your opinion and if
you want to go ahead and do it.
And I think my team sees that and I
really think you have to walk the walk and
talk the talk.
You can't talk about being brave,
you can't talk about
doing things differently.
You can't talk about taking risks
unless you personally take them.
And I think my team sees me
take them every single week. Um,
great example.
We're doing agency reviews right now.
We put all our business
up for review. And, um,
I was with our CEO last week and in front
of a bunch of people from my team and
he said,
well,
why don't I fly out and I'll meet with
some of these agencies with you and I'll
bring Jen who's our CFO? And
I said, no. He was like, what?
And I mean this was in front of everybody.
I said,
I'm not going to these agencies
with our CEO and the CFO,
they're never going to want to do
business with us. And he's like, okay,
fair enough.
You know,
you have to show your team that you're
brave enough and you've got the passion.
And then I think people will follow.
Well,
I think that that fits really good into
my next question about presence and your
ability just to be so down
to earth and saw authentic.
It just draws people to you.
I mean,
as you move up in your career and
now are sitting in the c suite, it,
it can be intimidating for others.
But when I met with you and presented
with you in front of a bunch of dealers,
right?
It was like talking to your best friend.
So I just want to hear about how have
you spoke about a little bit here,
but how you maintain that
and why that is so funny.
Well, thank you. First of all,
I have, I have a lot of sayings,
but another favorite saying of mine
has never drink your own koolaid. Um,
and I hate as I grew up in the agency
business and I think a lot of you guys
probably have seen the same thing,
right?
As people get in bigger and bigger jobs,
they become more and more precious.
It's like,
you know,
our old CEO didn't want any
potato chips that were brown.
So as Admin used to like pluck out
the burned potato chips, I'm like,
are you kidding me? If, and
I've always thought to myself,
if I ever get like that,
somebody, please shoot me. I
never want to be that person. Um,
so I've all, and I also know
that a job can be over like this,
especially in the CSUITE. You look at
things like average tenure of a Cmo,
18 months and you know,
you get a new CEO or you get a board
member or you do something and,
or the KPIs are going in the
right direction and you're out.
And so my belief is,
um,
if I take myself too seriously and if I,
if I put off that I'm a Cmo,
so I'm better than everybody air.
Um, nobody wants to be around me and
who wants to be around people like that.
It isn't very fun and it's not fun for
me either because I learn from the people
on my team every single day. And if
they're intimidated by being around me,
it's a bad place to be. So I've always
kind of straight stayed true to that.
Never drink your own Koolaid, never let
a job or a career define you. You know,
when I'm,
when I decide to kind of hang it up,
I want to be defined by the kind of
leader I was, the kind of person I was,
the legacy that I left on
advertising and marketing.
And I want people to say
she was a really cool chick.
I don't want them to say she was
an arrogant idiot. Thank you.
Um, do you mind speaking a little bit to
the last time that you shared? I mean,
it's really amazing how transparent
you are about who you are as a mom.
Um,
how would you say you maintained that
relationship with your boys as they grew
and, and also this role so far? Yeah. You
know, um, everybody talks about balance.
Whoever like came up the word
with the word and balance.
I don't care if you're a man or a woman
in business, there's no balance. It just,
it's ridiculous and
it's, um, it's, you know,
fairy tale land to believe that
you can achieve it. And so for me,
my thought was always,
um, I'm going to be,
I'm going to make what I do matter.
And I have a platform where
I can make my son's into,
you know, really good men and, um,
I can give them experiences that they
could never get if I didn't have this job.
And so a lot of what I did is,
first of all,
I picked the things that were really
important to them and I never missed those
things. So I think a good example is
when my son was a senior in high school,
he was on the varsity hockey team and it
was really important to him that I was
there and I travel a ton and I made a
commitment to them at the beginning of the
season and I said,
I'm not going to miss any of your games.
And no what I had to do.
I made it to every single game.
Now if any of you guys are hockey parents,
you know,
you're talking to like 60 games and
I just establish that, you know,
with my boss. And I said, I'm
not gonna miss any of his games.
So I'd literally be like on a three day
trip and if he had a game on Tuesday,
I leave on Tuesday afternoon,
I'd fly to the game and I'd
fly back either that night
or early the next morning.
Um,
the other thing that I always did is I
brought my boys as much as I could with
me.
So when I traveled,
I brought them with me and
they got to see me in action.
I bring them to things like this. I still
do, I bring them to inner, you know,
interact with dealers. Um, they were
always my date for everything. You know,
I was single, so it was my
two boys and me. Um, and they,
they learned about being in big cities.
They learned about getting
around airports. They, you know,
you can drop either one of them into any
situation and they're not intimidated
by it. Um, and then the time
that I was home with them,
I just was like really present
in the moment. My phone was down.
I wasn't on my computer and the
time that we had was for us.
And today we have the closest
relationship. Um, you know,
and I've got two step kids now and I'm
trying to do the same thing with them and
just give them an opportunity to
kind of see the world through my Lens
in school.
I used to try to be at everything and
you just can't know really finding out
what they need you. You got to give
yourself a break. Like I'll tell you,
but you know, women
have horrible guilt. Um,
but I think this advice goes for men
or women. Lie Yourself off the hook.
It's okay. Like, do you think that
now that my son's 21 years old,
he's ever going to remember that I didn't
go to one parent teacher conference.
I didn't, he doesn't talk about
that when he's around his friends,
he talks about my mom's got this awesome
job and she's a CMO and she's done this,
this and this.
That's what he talks about and he
talks about the things that we've done
together. He doesn't talk about those
kinds of things. So give yourself a break,
you know, be where you need to
be when you need to be there.
But a lot of that stuff, don't worry
about it. They're never going to remember.
Of course.
One more question I'll turn
to the audience about to
try and specifically one of
the big buildings we see your big purple.
I like to call the crown building.
Yeah.
We're coming down there too.
I'm excited to have you guys down there
and anything you were mentioning how
much you love being down there even
though you drive a very long way to,
I do give us some things to look forward
to or things that you really love. Yeah.
So we were one of the first big companies
to move back or to move everybody
downtown. We had half of our employees
were there and then we had some people in
Southfield and Auburn hills and kind of
spread out all over the place. And um,
you know,
we had announced that we are going to
actually be moving out of the city and
Mayor Duggan came to us and said,
give me two weeks to put a plan together
to keep you guys in the city of Detroit.
And he called Dan Gilbert and said,
buy a building.
We need to keep them down here.
And he bought that building and um,
we rebranded it to ally center
and we did something really cool.
I actually got to do the design working
with the architects and the design firm
and we gutted 15 floors and we designed
every floor like a different Detroit
neighborhood. So everyone is, um,
an homage to a different Detroit
neighborhood and it's a really cool way we
sourced all the materials from those
neighborhoods. So for instance,
Corktown all the,
um,
all the wood on the floor is from trees
that had fallen in Corktown and we've
got the stories of those neighborhoods
on each one of the floors.
So we've got big murals with the story
of each one of those neighborhoods.
And it's a great way to kind of teach the
next generation about the city because,
you know, I grew up going downtown
all the time, but my kids didn't.
And I'm sure a lot of the
people in this room did it.
And it's like getting people to
fall in love with the city again.
It's awesome being down there. Um, we
pride ourselves on being one of Detroit's,
you know,
favorite children,
we believe really strongly in supporting
everything that's important to the city.
So whether it's the 4th of July, the
fireworks and sponsoring those, um,
you know,
sponsoring things with the,
with the red wings and the
Tigers and the lions, um,
being really active in charities
and giving back to the city,
um, having people volunteer and
we've just really immersed ourselves.
So I would tell you guys, get out,
have fun, especially in the summer.
There's so many awesome restaurants
down there now. Um, stay late,
have a good time while
you're down there and,
and throw yourself into everything that's
going on in the vibe down there is so
creative and so awesome right
now that it's just really,
really inspiring to be downtown.
I wouldn't want to be anyplace else.
And where your Detroit pride,
I actually got the old English
d tattooed on my back, so
I had to represent,
now we're going to turn to the
audience for any additional questions.
Does anybody have any questions to ask?
Andrea
chicken.
Hi Andrea. A lot of us actually got our
start on the agency side as well too.
So when you mentioned that you were in
that big role at 35 at Campbell Ewald
it's not that I was ever at a big role.
I was no one,
but I did also start on
the creative agency side.
So I'm wondering what do you think
now as a CMO who's being brave,
taking a lot of really cool
disruptive marketing challenges,
what do you think from that time on the
agency side prepped you best and makes
you competitive in a great weapon?
No, it's, that's a great question. Um, and
I'm sure you were somebody at the agency,
so don't sell yourself short.
Um, so first and foremost,
I think that what I learned on the
agency side is just about creativity.
And I know how to get great
creativity out of an agency.
That's a really important attribute,
right? Because you guys know,
especially in the creative world,
clients saw off all sharp edges.
Like you get a really cool idea and by
the time it's done going through the
spanking machine, it's sucks when it
comes out the other end. And so I'm,
I'm very, very protective
of the creative process. Um,
you know, I, I really, well I try and
kind of bring our business partners along.
I try and really shield the creative
process and I think that agencies feed off
of that protection and that agency.
Um,
I think the second thing is the golden
gut that I talked about. Like I,
I know when I see potential in an idea
and you guys remember from your agency
days and ideas, not always perfect
the first time, but you know,
when there's something there and a lot
of clients that just kind of grew up on
the client's side the whole time,
they either test it and it dies
or they can't see the potential.
They don't know how to keep moving it
along and making it better and making it
into something more powerful than it was
when it started. And then I think third,
um,
just the ability to stand up and
present and have a presence and you
underestimate how important that
is in business. But you know,
when you're standing in
front of a board and, um,
you need to be able to deliver really
powerfully a point of view around
something that's potentially
controversial or you know,
when your boss says you're
going to present it investor
day and you're in a room
and you're,
you know,
and you're in front of 500 people that
are thinking about investing in your
company and what you say could affect
your stock price and the way that your
company goes forward. Like if you,
and everything in between, right.
If you don't have that ability to have
that presence and those presentation
skills, um, it's a really tough road.
So those things were
really important to me.
I really took those from my
agency time. Yeah, go for it.
Nothing's off bowels.
I'll tell you anything you want to know.
Check. Um, so Andrea, uh,
Mike Orlando again. Um,
thank you again for coming in.
I feel like allies,
one of the undervalued stories of Detroit.
Um,
can you talk a little bit about culture,
what you guys are doing within the walls
of ally, what your CEO's, you know,
yeah. The core objectives
are. Yeah, no, that's a great
question. And I agree. I mean,
part of our, it's funny, you'd think
that 10 years has been a long time,
but it's not for a brand and it's not
for a brand that doesn't spend the brand
spend in the category.
So just our ability to grow sheer
awareness and get the story out there,
um, has been tough. And, and honestly,
a big part of it was because
we are so reactive and PR.
And when I took on PR
responsibility last year,
we said we're going to really go out and
start to be really proactive and that's
helped us a lot. The company
is an amazing company. Um,
our CEO is 44 years old. He is, um,
one of the five youngest
CEOs in the fortune 500. Um,
he believes very strongly culture when
he goes out and talks to
investors and they say, what,
what is going to separate you from all
of the other players in the financial
services category?
His first answer is always culture.
And a lot of investors are like, wow, no
one ever talks about culture. And, um,
he believes very strongly in a
number of things he believes first.
I think in foremost in
diversity and inclusion.
And I know that's a really popular thing
to say, but it's a harder thing to do.
If you look at our c suite and
our executive council out of, um,
probably 18 people on our
executive council, um,
we have at least eight
women in c suite positions.
Our chief human resources officer or chief
financial officer or the president of
our bank, myself. Um, you know, the
list kind of goes on and on. In fact,
our CFO is the only female CFO
in the entire banking industry,
which is staggering. Um, he's
established employee resource groups.
So we have 15 different employee
resource groups and, um,
you can join the employee resource group
that you either identify with or the
employee resource group that
you want to learn about.
And that's been an awesome way,
you know,
investing budget and time
for people to do that. Um,
he believes very strongly in being
purpose driven and we give everybody time.
Um, you know, we call it PTO time to, um,
our VTO time where they can volunteer
and do things that are important to them
and being a part of the community
and doing things really different.
So this month happens to be financial
literacy month and we did something really
cool for that where, um,
instead of just writing a check,
we actually wrote a children's book
called planet z and the money tree and it
teaches kids about money and the
fact that it doesn't grow on trees.
And we have all of our employees going
into schools and doing readings of planet
z in the money tree. And
if you go on, you know,
if you go on and of our social pages,
you'll be able to either download a copy
and then we're donating hardcopies to,
to schools as well.
Um,
and then the other big thing that
I would say with him is he's not a
micromanager and nobody had ally is,
and we let people kind of
sore their wings and go,
we have a culture of innovation.
We're digital financial services.
So we have to stay on the leading edge.
Maybe not always the bleeding edge,
but on the leading edge.
And you have to create a
culture of innovation and
you have to a invest in that.
Even though everybody's always
talking about how do I cut expenses.
So he's very good about
invest, invest, invest and to,
he's not afraid to let us fail.
So you can take reasonable
risks and if you fail,
it's a good thing to learn from. And
there's no punishment on the other end.
You don't lose your job, you know, you
don't get a slap on the risks, the risks,
you know, even little things like putting
that Motley Crue music on the spot.
Like I said, our board was really about
it and he was like, if you want to do it,
you do it. You're the CMO, good or bad,
you know, it's on you and I support you.
So I think those are the things
that are happening in ally.
It's an awesome company. Um, we're going
through these agency pitches right now.
As I mentioned,
for me,
I think the next big thing I want to do
is just create this awakening around how
great the company is,
how differentiated our product is,
and just get people to pay
attention to their money again,
and that's what we're really trying to do.
Yup.
All right. Thank you again. Thank
you guys. Thanks for having me.
[inaudible].